[Music]
is zack snyder's justice league a hit it
seems like it
based on the anecdotal evidence of buzz
and conversation around hbo max's
streaming exclusive director's curt of
the dc comic superhero epic
but since streaming services generally
don't release detailed viewer data and
when they do say how many people watch
something there's no reliable way to
check it
people who want to quantify the success
of a piece of streaming entertainment
have a harder time doing it
when trying to measure the popularity of
a streaming movie or show there are no
easy numbers like box office grosses for
theatrical releases or nielsen ratings
to broadcast tv shows
the only way is to try to quantify it
require muddled estimates of ambiguous
metrics that don't provide anything
close to a complete picture
we will probably never know for sure how
many people watched ben affleck's batman
finally meet jared leto's joker and all
the hours leading up to that moment
that being said the grain of salt
numbers we do have should be very
exciting for anyone invested
in the success of the snyder cut
bloomberg reports that downloads of the
hbo
max mobile app increased 64 for the week
ending march 28th
over the previous week according to
updater analysis service apptopia
1.48 million people downloaded the app
though as forbes notes that number isn't
necessarily new subscribers
as it may include users who already had
access to hbo max but hadn't yet
activated the mobile app bloomberg also
reports an 8.9
increase in users opening the app a
total of 119.1 million launches
those numbers sound big but let's put
them in context they are indeed good
numbers
especially compared to hbo max's
competitors for the same week bloomberg
reports 69.7 million app sessions for
disney plus an
increase of 0.4 from the previous week
and a 4
increase in mobile app downloads
disney's streaming service already has
over 100 million subscribers
according to the verge while hbo max is
projected to have between
67 and 70 million subscribers by the end
of the year so hbo max's app
outperformed disney plus the same week
disney plus premiered a new marvel
limited series the falcon and the winter
soldier
not too shabby no other app showed that
kind of user growth in the week that
ended on march 28th
according to uptopia's data netflix app
downloads actually declined by 1
though netflix market dominance means
that growth will naturally be slower
netflix has over 200 million subscribers
worldwide
according to cnbc there are also
positive numbers for people streaming
zack snyder's justice league on other
devices too
samba tv another third party data
analytics app
reports that 2.2 million u.s households
and
954 000 uk households watched the film
in its first week of release on
opted in smart tvs with automatic
content recognition technology the
limited nature of that data set
means the actual number is likely much
higher the viewer numbers for zack
snyder's justice league are below wonder
woman 1984's first week viewer estimate
over 3 million american households watch
patty jenkins won the woman sequel
on hbo max in the week between christmas
and new year's
fortunately wonder woman 1984 is more of
a sibling competitor
the actual threat came from the falcon
and the winter soldier which zack
snyder's justice league appears to have
handily overcome
according to deadlines samba tv found
1.8 million households watched at least
five of the movies 242 minutes and the
movie's first three days of release
while 1.7 million households watch the
marvel limited series in the same time
frame
justice league's victory is also pretty
impressive in light of the fact that the
avengers endgame sequel series is disney
plus
biggest series premiere yet according to
variety
posting higher first weekend numbers
than one division and the mandalorian
of course the viewer numbers themselves
aren't the most important metric for
streaming services the most important
things are signups and subscriber
retention
it's a little too early to say at the 70
million dollars warner brothers put up
to finish
zack snyder's justice league was money
well spent in terms of driving and
retaining hbo max subscriptions
we may never know the film's profit and
loss even thinking about how to
calculate that is complicated
and maybe it doesn't matter if the
slider cuts true purpose was to plant
positive feelings about hbo max
in the minds of millions of people a t
the parent company of the warner media
conglomerate
is probably happy with the result check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about zack
snyder's justice league are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one